Steven Kotler welcome to flow sessions
Jason Silva it's good to be with you
brother how are you man I'm really well
how are you well I'm thrilled to have
you you and I have been friends for a
number of years I love your brain I just
I have respect you I'm in awe of you I
often call you late at night when I have
some deep pressing question about
neuroscience consciousness psychedelics
altered states techno utopianism and all
that jazz and I thought man we've done
all these live events together we've
recorded our conversations on stage
together but we've never really done
something where we have absolute control
over the environment and I'm hoping that
this is an opportunity for us to get a
deep dive you're gonna mess with me
right like the environment is gonna
change dancing girls are gonna so often
when we're together I have I am left
with many more questions and so I
thought that this was an opportunity for
us to really deep dive into so many
things do it so here we go man
flow saved your life that's it this is
one of the things that you've written
about talked about you've written a book
about human performance called the rise
of Superman you co-wrote stealing fire
you are known as an expert in flow the
state of consciousness in which human
beings feel their very best and perform
their very best and in an age where
everyone's looking for a quick fix the
self-help guide to a happy life I am
curious for those that don't know and
also for me to hear it again what is
flow exactly why is it so addicting and
or irresistible how can it make our
lives better and how did it save
your life let's start with definitions
please you had the right definition like
you the scientific deficient flow is
what you is what you said more
colloquial right it's those moments of
rapt attention and total absorption
where people get so focused on the task
at hand that everything else just
disappears extra awareness will merge
since the self-awareness time dilates
which is a fancy way of saying it passes
strange they write sometimes slows down
freeze-frame effect more for him the
speeds up in the 5 hours passed by in
like 5 minutes
and throughout all aspects of
performance mental and physical go
through the roof so that's the
colloquial definition that's the
phenomenology right that's the
experience that's the felt about this
behind falls away your sense of self
vanishes you're freed from the monkey
mind and being or chat or all of these
things I always like to point out oh
because this wasn't the case for a
really long time but it is the case now
is that when we say flow now when
researchers say flow what they're really
saying is a very precise like we
understand what neural chemicals are
show up in the state we understand what
neuro electricity does in the state we
know which networks are active and which
ones are enacted we know which parts of
the brain are active and which ones are
inactive we know what a lot of your
physiological signals are and by the way
the physiology when I wrote rise a
Superman just that were I don't even
know if that work has been published yet
so this is all in the past five six
years we have made massive amounts of
progress and sort of decode in the
neurobiology of flow and one by we I
mean all the researchers in the field
I've got I've got a lab but I I mean
everybody's working on this stuff to
answer your second question which is why
do we like it so much what's the big
deal so um among the other things that
happen in flow is you get some
combination of five extremely potent
pleasure chemicals norepinephrine
dopamine and amide endorphins and
serotonin possibly serotonin um so you
get flooded with yeah and these are all
feel-good drugs right so every time
there's a drug in the world
it's an exogenous chemical right we have
endogenous versions they're like when we
take coke
Kaine but this was this was how he
learned about neural chemistry people
were getting addicted to heroin yeah
this is 50 60s and people were like well
here's a drug that's 2,000 years old
yeah
what's it attaching to in the brain
that's producing this addiction yeah
right and we discovered we have natural
and heroin right endorphins right and
also just to give you an idea so you get
endorphins and flow about 20 different
endorphins in the brain the most common
one which shows up in flow is a hundred
times more potent than medical morphine
you so when we say you're getting
pleasure chemicals right like the brains
version is much better than the street
drug first of all most of the time
second of all you can't cocktail the
street versions of it if you were to
like take like I just listed cocaine is
dopamine norepinephrine is speed Ananda
mine is marijuana
serotonin is is either ecstasy MDMA or
LSD depending on the pathway right
norepinephrine is speed you want to do
those combinations of street drugs
you're going to probably end up in the
hospital or in a coma or debt doesn't
work
brain cocktails them naturally and
normally which is really quite amazing
because like for example it is very
difficult people who if people to
experiment with MDMA and cocaine for
example will discover that the cocaine
wins dopamine is more powerful than
serotonin essentially and will swamp the
experience and you'll you'll be on
cocaine you won't be on Molly the brain
seems to allow some coexistence between
these substances and they can both be in
your system sort of at the same time
right so we can do stuff internally that
you can't do externally so the big deal
here is a big deal is that it's
essentially the best high in the world
if you can get a unique chemical
composition experience we like the most
these times we like them and these are
the moments that take our breath away
these are the endless summers this is
like falling in love for the first time
this is like witnessing the birth of a
child this is like the sport that you
love the most in the world where you
lose track of time I mean this is it's
all that stuff poetry has made a couple
things
worth pointing out also is it's not just
pleasure he was just pleasure was just a
high right soon some pleasure coupled
with performance and meaning that's the
key is so when positive psychologists
talk about happiness they talk about
three levels of happiness that you can
obtain level one is happiness it's
pleasure it's hedonism how do you feel
right now
sure and the truth of the matter is we
have emotional set points there's only
so much you can do there yeah you can
have a gratitude practice yeah you can
have a meditation practice
yeah it'll make you feel a little bit
better but it's not its root there's not
a big lever there right with pleasure
just happiness yet with just pleasure
it's a lousy strategy well I'm happy
I've had conversations and some people
don't fully understand where I say that
for me sexual satisfaction is
cognitively oriented that I am
cognitively oriented that if I just have
physical pleasure that if I just treat
sex physiologically you know like oh
drop into your body like feel the
sensations that that's actually doesn't
give me as much pleasure like if I want
to do that I could just self pleasure
masturbate and have the physiological
response of orgasm and that's it but the
true satisfaction what really arouses
and engages me has always been
cognitively oriented what is the scene
that is unfolding what is my sexual
partner doing how is she surrendering in
a way that makes me want to surrender
what is the boost of esteem that I'm
getting from being mirrored by this
person or seen in a certain way the
scene of the setting the framing the
movie is a is cognitively oriented and
it's what gets me off because it's
preoccupied with meaning what does this
mean and it's the layer of meaning that
that it built on top of the physical
pleasure that is where I get the real
pleasure so it sounds like you're
talking about that happiness these
engagements a high engagement life we're
at lots of flow there it's a high flow
lifestyle so level two level one is
pleasure level two is high flow level
three is high flow plus purpose so I'm
doing something that produces a
tremendous amount of flow
that is serving a cause greater than
myself oh this reminds me levels well
this reminds me of that equation that
Venn diagram that you came up with for
that Forbes article you wrote about how
to find your passion and then I won I
don't want to like get off topic of flow
but just for those that are listening
because this was very interesting is
that people often struggle with finding
their passion there's such a pressure in
the world telling you that if you find
your passion you'll find happiness
you'll find things and people that want
the falkland I don't know like I'm just
figuring it out you know and so what you
said was you know maybe what you want to
start with is making a list of things
you're curious about those are easier to
identify than like your one North Star
your one passion so you're like make a
list of 5 to 15 thing 25 25 minutes
you're really curious about and then
find a couple that overlap how many was
it yeah it's I 3 to 5 3 to 5 to overlap
and then you say when multiple your
multiple curiosity well curiosity's
overlap is a sign of neurobiology it
means you're starting to get that
combination of pleasure and meaning and
cognitive engagement and all that jazz
because there's multiple curiosities
like overlapping like how beautiful that
is and so then that's like the beginning
of your passion and then you say find a
need in the world that can be served by
these overlapping curiosities and now
the passion turns into a purpose it's
like you were hitting at dab but I guess
this whole thing is connected back to
this flow like pleasures on the same
number one level to happiness so keep
going since all this time out yeah flow
states have triggers preconditions that
lead to more flow right this is a lot of
the work that I've been involved in okay
so this goes into the idea of like how
do i how to train how to train for flow
how to contextualize or preconditions
spaces that lead to the emergence of
flow like a flame that comes into
existence when the conditions are right
let's talk about it yeah at the flow
research collected my organization yeah
our trainings closed really trainable is
my point like we are getting and we're
using the same psychometric considering
everybody else is measuring flow with
csikszentmihalyi's original scale
where'd she send me hi and I learned how
to say his name
nice we're getting an 80% boost and flow
on the backend my point is it's really
trainable there is a massive return to
baseline afterwards in certain patient
populations
usually peak performers can keep going
everybody else's bigger turn to baseline
and there are a number of reasons for
that we don't have to go into that my
point is it's trainable and what we're
training people on low is trainable
these triggers right flow follows focus
it shows up when all of our attention is
in the right here right now that's what
all the triggers do so flow follows
focus because often when people hear uh
flow or they watch my videos where I
seem to be in flow or they read your
books all about flow or they see elite
athletes constantly superseding what
came before and pushing the limitations
of human possibility being in these
states of flow everybody's like well how
do I get that if I'm not a professional
snowboarder how do I get that and so
you're talking about these flow triggers
and the first thing you say is the flow
follows focus so attention is a
precursor for a flow experience
let me put it make it one step their
cookies big neuro Neuroscience um it
appears the flow triggers do one of
three things they either push
norepinephrine or dopamine into our
system so norepinephrine is one of the
mains
it's a pleasure chemical but it's one of
the main focusing chemicals right we
feel it as excitement or anxiety but we
feel as excitement but more attention to
the president
dopamine same thing pleasure and a lot
of attention in the present
so the flow triggers are either pushing
dopamine into your system to drive focus
and thus push you into flow
norepinephrine or they're lower in
cognitive load so all the [ __ ] you're
trying to think about it once right the
weight of the now if I lower that you
have more energy to pay attention to the
present right but that's the thing
that's not always easy right flow
follows focus and focusing on the
present is typically elusive because
human beings now spend a lot of time
either worried about the future or
regretting or replaying events from the
past one of the most interesting
passages in Michael Pollan's new book
how to change your mind about
psychedelic psychotherapy was actually
the preface where he kind of has this
paragraph that describes sort of the the
the essence of the human default setting
and he says look the brain is like an
artificial intelligence program takes in
data from the present and
pairs that with data from the past and
uses it to make predictions about the
future
so we're future tense with a low-level
hum of anxiety at all times and then has
this funny line the good news is I'm
seldom surprised right nothing's gonna
sideline me cuz I'm always preparing and
mitigating against future threats but
then he goes but the bad news is I'm
seldom surprised nothing ever delights
me or surprises me in a good a positive
way so then he goes on you know after
after after this bummer
of the low-level hum of anxiety future
tense orientation he says that what
commends travel beauty and certain kinds
of drugs and I would argue that all of
these things potentially are flow
triggers what commends them is that they
knock all signals forwards and backwards
offline so the future predicting trying
to imagine what's next end up comparing
with the past they get knocked off line
hurling us into the flow of the present
right his words flow of the present I
don't even know he was even he knew he
was using the term flow but flow of the
present and I continued to quote a
present that is literally wonder - full
wonderful right wonder being the
byproduct of that unencumbered sense of
first sight or virginal noticing to
which the adult brain has closed itself
now wonder for me wonder in awe is one
of the most positively enjoyable
subjective States there can be but
wonder requires that unencumbered sense
of first sight that childlike innocence
that non adult jaded miss that is the
bin there's and scene that's of the
adult mind which is again part of our
future orient default setting because
it's so [ __ ] hard to stop and smell
the roses or Blake's world in a grain of
sand and heaven in a wild flower
infinity in the palms of our hands an
eternity in an hour because again flow
follows focus sounds like a simple
formula but it's really [ __ ] hard to
focus on the present because our default
is not that our default is
future-oriented
and negatively parsing that future and
mitigating against future risk
it's the 21st century neurotic default
setting so back to the question of hand
flow triggers right things that can
knock those signals forwards and
backwards offline so that way me we may
be present or free up the cognitive
real-estate to be present so that flow
can follow focus so how the [ __ ] do we
do that what are the triggers Devon
triple right so we're gonna get novelty
yes complexity unpredictability pattern
recognition linking ideas together risk
these are all dopamine triggers right
this is all driving massive quantities
of okay so but I have to a relationship
for one year and my girlfriend will
criticize me because she says that all I
want is to always be traveling around
that I let I like novelty so much and
that that somehow makes me a difficult
person to date because she she says I
never be satisfied in a stable situation
because I always want to change things
up and go explore and trigger now and I
talked about novelty as if it's oxygen
I'm like what do you like I'm like I
like novelty I need to go to new places
I need to go to new hikes I need to go
to new things I need to have new comer
size because otherwise my default is
this like neurotic footage the other
thing is you don't I mean you're in
novelty yeah but your novelty is really
bounded you want specific kinds of you
want and you like right it's not I'm
open to anything then bring it on it's
no I really like hiking and nature and
if you want to show me do some different
nature I'm down Yeah right and your city
like your list of cities like Jason you
want to go like backpacker and ulama
tour and you know with a nav secular yes
no no I know you right it's a very so
you want novelty inside so you can tell
her to just calm down it's you only want
novelty and things that she already
likes to do so save my relationship this
is huge because this back to the flow
triggers because I know the people
listening at home or after you know I do
if people always asking me like you know
what's what's the recipe so so let's
really unpack what constitutes novelty
how much do you have to violate your
expectation let's start really simple
okay right like Chris's like first thing
I do when I walk into an organization is
look guys if you can't hang a sign on
your door this is [ __ ] off I'm flowing
can't do this work flow demands under
period uninterrupted periods of
concentration well that's why I set up
the studio like this first so like first
thing I have people do is when you
finish your work day at the end of your
work day distraction management anything
to distract you from your first
90-minute work session the next day turn
it off the night before shut down your
email shut down your phone turn up a bla
bla bla bla bla right if your main
distractions are your kids or your
husband or your right whatever it is
you've got this 90-minute period that
I'm going to start my day with and
unless your circadian rhythms are such
that you're a night owl you want it to
be first thing in the morning right like
that's when we're most focused most
alert most able to do our artists tasks
unless you're a night owl and then you
want to start your night owl session
that way right well for me it's drinking
coffee but like my girlfriend after that
oh okay but my girlfriend will often
tell me and this is interesting that her
morning sacred practice is crucial
alright she wants to sit and meditate
and drink her tea for that first hour
and a half in the morning people have
these people have these people have
these morning sacred practices and I
totally respect that and I guess the
question for me is you know when I hear
somebody make a make a demand about a
morning practice I'm like well I can do
that with me but I guess what you're
saying morning practice - what you're
saying is that we should be really
strict and and non compromising about
what we know yes so one morning okay
performance peak performance across the
boards I always say this to people under
the hood peak performance doesn't look
like anything other than a checklist
you'll wake up you got ten things on
your checklist you great at all them and
when you're done with your checklist
you're gonna get some exercise
you're gonna eat high quality food
you're gonna have an active recovery
practice you're not just gonna sit down
drink a beer watch TV right you're gonna
do some yoga get a song I take a hot
pack right you can take care of your
body a little bit yeah and then you're
gonna try to have some sign of social
contact right what
DC and Ryan call relatedness
yeah like that's and then you do it
again that's what high performance
really looks like another hood it's just
so it's so funny because I often you
know people one of the criticisms that I
get from from people who are close to me
friends and and people that know me a
little bit is that they love my videos
and they see this looseness and this
dance and this flow and this jazz in the
content that I do when I'm at my most
creative my most low and then they ask
me all these questions about it and when
I list my preconditions and my checklist
and my and all the discipline that goes
into orienting my life around these
states they're like they're like dude
like you need to learn to like surrender
like just like let go and like loosen up
and lighten up and and and and while I
know that they mean it from a good place
because they they sense in me a
controlling tendency but the Venn
diagram that I prefer going back to this
Venn diagram analysis is is flow is what
is in between discipline and surrender
yeah not just surrender it's also not
just discipline but that when they
overload assignable disappoints or in
the whole notion that flow has anything
to do with surrender you're just that's
a whole bunch so what float does produce
dangers aster wrote about it in stealing
fire we'll get into that will put this
is classic example of bliss junkie dumb
people taste a little bit of flow and
they're like oh I just have to surrender
to my life in-out the card you're out of
your freaking mind like that's not how
the state works at all so please get
into this these games that the dangers
of this of this cult of surrender well
it's so let me give you a mountain
biking is a great example okay um this
happens all the time by the way two
mountain bikers I like even mountain
bikers will make this mistake um you'll
want to go out for a flowy ride right
mountain biking especially I'm a
downhill ER but even cross-country can
be this with mom making a violent sport
it is a especially downhill violent the
bike shakes you have to like it requires
a lot if you go out and try to have a
flowy mountain bike ride you're going to
the hospital
you
to attack the freaking mountain in fact
this is not this is Greg Burns work a
brilliant mind at Emory he argued in his
book satisfaction that at the end
there's proof for this that are the
front end of a flow state before you can
get into flow so we know two things
happen one you have a the challenge goes
up right there's and there in your brain
you're getting you have a negative
reaction
you literally go crap right you have one
of those be right before you go into
flow it always happens and then you Greg
burns our Kurds if you meet that with
testosterone and that that leads into
dopamine which leads into flow I don't
know if he's right nobody's looked at
the testosterone theory yet yeah but it
Maps if you talk to you have to attack
to get into flow because you need all
that focus yeah there's nothing Mel you
don't day trip into flow it doesn't work
that way
it's an action stain you have to work to
get in it and by the way everything you
just said I think even in zero to
dangerous or in the training that I do I
don't I can't put a number out about
fifty is sixty percent of what I'm doing
is teaching you how to put flow at the
center of your schedule and filled your
life around it right that's what the
best organizations have done that's what
the best individuals have done and
you're absolutely right you you need a
pretty rigorous scheduler you need
flexibility inside of it right I do
right you want flexibility inside your
limits absolutely have to have those
limits and once you try to remove them
right what you see in the whole Burning
Man cart the hippie crowd all like no
you're actually you're probably gonna
make yourself miserable waiting for a
state that's not gonna show up because
you're not you're getting the very
things you're not doing disease well
it's like that book right after the
ecstasy the laundry or the whole thing
attaching water and chopping wood or
flow bears line that says be disciplined
and orderly in your life so that you may
be violent and original in your work but
essentially the same thing so when I
tell people I'm like look my flow allows
me to supersede my limits again and
again and again my gymnastics you know
my achieving the impossible that I do in
my career
work or I aspired to do in my accretive
work means that in many other aspects of
my life I am monk-like and circumscribed
and discipline I'm disciplined about my
sleep I'm disciplined about quiet I'm
just applying about when I eat I'm
disciplined about when I go to the
bathroom like I'm super disciplined all
the other weight and get how you have I
mean like your discipline like people
have no idea how much discipline there
is that's right yeah it's nice but but
it has become this thing where it's like
because what what we produce when were
in flow feels like ecstatic surrender
right you move beyond the self and
you're free of the discipline in it it
presents itself that way experientially
looks that way people mirror it that way
yes people in response to that have
participated in the creation of this
expectations cult of surrender
everybody's like just let go or you just
have to surrender
just surrender let go and it is this the
cult of surrender has come at the
expense of I think the rigor and the
hard work and the discipline that goes
into building your life around these
states that allow your limitation
ignorant of the biology is what it is
it's just ignorant of the bias I mean
like it incident I always say and this
is a core thing for me and I'll tell you
this these people what happens is they
have flow like experiences once and then
they think that biology isn't real
the soul is immaterial and then you just
have to let go 150 years who knows right
okay but let's continue on this so we're
talking about these flow triggers and
we're talking about novelty and we're
talking about how do you had an
instrument a kind of novelty how to be
disciplined in in crafting that I guess
you could call it a second like a
psychedelic trip what's the set what's
the setting
what's the intention with the pre
expectation college like my ordination
partner with inferior college work
Mendel claim and Mendel has developed a
diagonal Mendel College of London by the
way is doing all this amazing
psychedelic research
card hard Harris and and Mendel Kailyn
is doing the wave path with branches
using music to help people achieve
psychedelic healing with just music
tripping on music well he's also
designing music for psychedelic therapy
right brilliant Darien great work yeah
but Mendel so said in setting right he
goes back to the 60s and we know this at
the amenda last or the great question
four or five years ago but what the
fuck'd is said in setting me yeah right
and he realized that nobody from a
scientific perspective oh you didn't
have to take the cap off I didn't know
that um I thought it was just Stephen
proof because he knew I was gonna knock
it over
but now Mendel can handle sentence
realized that we didn't know what
sentence heading meant so he set out to
build a diagnostic for said in setting
what do we actually mean by sudden
setting what real factors go into a blah
blah and I think it was a huge
diagnostic in the beginning I think
they've got it shrunk down somewhere on
fifty questions so we took that we took
there are 22 flow triggers that we know
of right and we map them onto one
another and we're still doing we just
wrapped it actually last week we did a
big study multi-year study comparing
sudden setting for psychedelic
experiences versus oh you know what's so
crazy about hearing you say this that
this is something that intuitively has
emerged for me in conversation where I'm
like yet set and setting is everything
maybe it's because I have a relationship
with cannabis and flow and cannabis has
been used by jazz musicians forever for
its improvisational capacity as a
catalyst for improvisation or freestyle
rappers and cannabis but cannabis is
also a kind of psychedelic it is a
psychedelic and so set and setting tends
to inform the experience that you have
and because I associate cannabis with
flow and I know that I have to be
sensitive for set and setting as with
all plant medicines and psychoactives
van nuys don't say the phrase plant
Renison around me we're doing drugs big
boy yes drug okay so so but back to this
idea that me attributing the importance
or identifying the importance of set and
setting as precursors for flow and also
precursors for psychedelics make sense
set and setting for flow is essentially
the flow triggers are you what
the way and you're particularly
susceptible yeah to certain triggers
right like there are certain triggers
that aren't gonna work for you at all I
can if you write like novelty right you
like a certain amount of dopamine and
that's complexity right and when I say
complexity I don't mean I'm confused I
mean the brain geological time right
you're standing at the edge of the Grand
Canyon and your brain goes oh my god
this is right like cognitively oriented
oriented well Diana Slattery once called
me a cognitive ecstasy addict she's not
wrong so cognitive ecstasy is that it's
contemplating certain kind of vastness
and then finding the language that is
that is poetic enough to implicate the
implications of said vastness you know
you're also you've done something really
interesting
I think yeah we're gonna know but I I've
noticed this um because you are very
susceptible to complexity and most
people are not and you have developed
the ability to look for what I mean by
complexity right to look for so you will
when you look at nature won't like we'll
be hiking around you will always point
out some element of vastness of
geological time of evolutionary right
you've trained your brain not only to
seek novelty flow trigger but to
actually boost it up because you're
looking for the complexity inside of it
that's a skill right look Donna it's and
Lexy's one of the hardest flow triggers
most people like yeah what can I do with
this like unpredictability I get like
I'll drive a different route home that
will work by the way right you switch
start spend an entire day eating with
your left hand if you're right-handed
drive all turn around look do it over
and over again you're gonna start you're
gonna get little dopamine hits yeah you
know what yes flow but complexity is a
hard one for people to work with um
you've gotten very good at because
you've trained your brain to not just
find the novelty but to find the
complexity inside the novelty that's a
tricky one that's hard not a lot of
people do that I don't even know if I
can do it as well as you do oh my god
this is so interesting
so okay so so so so so novelty risk all
these dinky is not just physical like
for all the people who think you have to
be an athlete for know so first of all
let's talk about a couple of things on
that tip one um work done by
Csikszentmihalyi
worked on my old organization work done
by my current organization were like
there's a lot of work along the way that
shows that cognitive flow intellectual
flow intellectual risk social risk
emotional risk right just as potent as
physical risk this hurl is you into the
president only works for those people
who enjoy physical risk right if you're
not wired for physical risk and I you
know what I mean motorcycles are you did
all this stuff is denied that so you're
getting your double me and elsewhere
that's right this is very interesting so
for me okay so travel beauty right
certain kinds of drugs it's the
combination of these things back to the
whole Michael Pollan list of the things
that commend we commend for their
capacity to hurl us into the flow of the
present and the present having these
qualities of an unencumbered sense of
first sight yeah but you saw ones that
we had substances because I just want to
clarify this yeah you have you're not
running around acting like a STONER you
are using marijuana in very I mean just
as disciplined as everything else right
I like whatever I always wanted to say
this cuz like whatever people think is
going on I'm like no no he did there's
massive periods of enforced sobriety on
the front end and on the back end and
everything like it's the whole container
is totally built for the experience I've
mapped this out so one of the best
definitions that I ever came across that
I think describes cannabis and other
psychoactives is that these substances
essentially create heightened resonance
with set and setting
so they increase reactivity to stimuli
both difference in salience are you
saying anything different than they
thought I'd crank up the salient now
maybe that means the same thing but this
is the phrase that I came across this
was rich Doyle writing about
psychedelics in his book Darwin's
pharmacy so great book psychedelics
increase reactivity to stimuli both from
within and from without which is the
same thing as saying you notice your own
thoughts and reflections more their
heightened your conscious processes are
heightened it's an amplifier of
conscious life but it also is
heightening your perceptual noticing of
the sense8 world so this heightened
resonance heightened suggestibility to
set and setting is just as important as
the sentence setting and the reason why
is you know Alain de Botton and his
wonderful book the art of travel says
you know you might look at a beautiful
brochure of like a perfect palm tree
I'll into place and then you spend all
this money to fly 14 hours to there and
then you [ __ ] get there you forget
that you have to bring yourself along
and there's a flicking fly biting you in
a mosquito and it's [ __ ] hot and
you're like [ __ ] it does it's not as fun
as the brochure but I would argue it's
because you went to the place and you're
in the sentence setting but you didn't
introduce the agent that increases
reactivity to the stimuli it's like you
can fly across the world searching for
paradise but if you don't take two hits
from that joint
the wallpaper won't do its work on you
so it's I mean I need to also make
myself more porous it's not just
identify the external fluid resource
aids making myself more suggestible so
if I would put it in neurobiological
terms right salience is cranked way
upright which salience is just the stuff
in I can see the stuff that's in front
of me right I'm having attention to the
stuff that's here right now yes very
salient no but when you're hungry food
is sailing on it so that's reality no no
but the thing you're getting at which a
Scott Barry Kaufman who you also know
has done some cool work on this as well
latent inhibition which is really it's a
weird phrase but what it means is how
long can you hold something in your
brain before your brain attaches meaning
to it because the minute the brain goes
meaning you're done the novelties got
like right so the problem
the old patterns right like things
you've already done you your brain
automatically assigns the meaning so
we're like what that's called the
benders and see that of the adults my
cannabis on and amide among as a neural
so for those that don't know and and
amide is the naturally occurring version
of cannabis that we have in our brains
and you can I guess up-up-up juice it
when you you've just mean when you take
cannabis yes it appears and there I
think there's a lot more work that needs
to be done and I don't think this latent
inhibition allows information comes in
it's really salient right like okay when
you're high yeah
you notice everything in its environment
its right don't immediately say it means
this right the minute you have you pause
there's a little pause yeah and that
little pause what the brain is doing is
instead of instead of it being a tight
cluster of neurons that are just talking
to it to itself right your buret whole
brain is talking to itself right so you
can get far bigger context far more
meaning comes in one of the reasons flow
is so meaningful right like you got to
ask yourself this question like where
does that meaning come from I think one
of the places is coming from is you're
literally getting to you're not looking
to reality through new eyes
you're looking allottee and you're just
not judging it as quickly you're
literally not judging it so one of the
things that actually happens in flow is
there's a partier brain part of the
medial prefrontal cortex that is
specifically and most of that party
brain actually stays really active for
this part shuts down and it's negative
fast negative judgments usually about
others and negatively pre configuring
whatever's happening sacked Lea presume
that goes away so all of us okay so this
reminds me this is David lensing in his
book on drugs which we both love was
proposed love which you turned me on to
and he has a chapter on cannabis where
he's explaining one of the things that
is that it does the phrase is
what he calls a dialectical pattern of
reconcilable estrangement with everyday
perception so cannabis yes creates a lot
of work yeah yeah so essentially
cannabis creates a new distance between
you and the familiar thing that's that
look that you're talking about there's
new distance between you and that
familiar relationship with that thing
you're looking at and then allows you to
forge a new relationship with that thing
that closes that distance so it creates
an estrangement it makes strange which
by the way is congruent with objects of
beauty whenever you see something
beautiful that's it's strange your stuff
in you there's this lag where you're
like looking at you can't believe what
you're seeing and then a subsequent
reconciliation a new relationship that
then closes that distance and that's why
he says things that things seem to
attain when when you're high in cannabis
and in that and then in that beautiful
halo things attain an archetypal quality
so a landscape will look like a
landscape painting every object stands
for all of its class right a tree
specific tree becomes the archetype of
create rhiness you know and that's what
that's in I don't know if that's just
his experience literature professor but
it resonates with me back to what you
were saying the salience in this space
and this lag between the shorthand
judgment and algorithms that we already
have developed as adult I know what this
is I've been on this hike before I know
where I know this is just another hike I
know this person I've had I've talked to
this person a thousand times I have to
listen to this person like the bin
there's in scene des at the adults mind
the familiar algorithms the autopilot
but then that flow and the flow that
follows focus and then introducing
something like like cannabis that
creates a new distance between you and
the everyday perception and the new
relationship with the close at that
distance but then you combine that with
actual novelty so your cognitive biases
would be lowered when I was argue how we
can test that we can test it but but
this is where this gets interesting
because
okay so if you're combining this agent
this this met this medicine or this flow
agent called cannabis which increases
salience heightens perception and
facilitates it creates a new distance
between you and and that which you're
perceiving this is this space that
you're talking about but then you're not
just taking cannabis in a familiar place
to make that familiar place new again
you're actually combining the cannabis
with an actual novel place then you're
compounding the effects so that is the
short-term memory disruption well that's
where it lays a role here so he says
that the short-term memory disruption by
the way it's not that it makes you
forget who you are forget your own
insights but what it does is it makes it
so that your pool of sense impressions
drains as quickly as it fills so it it
makes the passing moment into a discrete
series of of present now's when after
they're so like let's say I'm looking at
this landscape my pool of sense
impression fills I'm overwhelmed by what
I'm looking and then I keep walking and
I turn around and my cool sense
impression drained just as quickly and
now fill the Imaginex to me ask
questions on this yeah so there's my big
hero William James one of the first we
came up with the idea of stream of
consciousness yes the idea that you're
talking about that was his yeah but he
tried to measure how long does the now
laughs right
a very hysterical study because he
literally said in his office of Harvard
in the 1880 90s with a stopwatch trying
to time his thoughts and he came up with
he said it was 12 to 30 seconds and
interestingly we have now measured that
using atomic clock like it's about 14
seconds he was off by two seconds lost
14 seconds but there are versions of the
now that will last 30 seconds you have
an orgasm that's a now that it's gonna
last a little longer than 14 seconds
right so my question is do you think
that cannabis extends the now do you
think the now is longer I think it's
like a sustain pedal so it's like if
you're playing the piano and you hit a
chord right and then I think cannabis
hits the sustain pedal on the chord and
Spanish the expression is the gap big
owl which basically means like you you
stay
for a minute a little long like whatever
you're like spirit front end of all yeah
like the reverb is heightened okay gotta
you know and and so it's hits a sustain
pedal and then I would argue that the
the sentence setting is the melody the
note and you are the instrument so you
are the instrument and then you hide you
really get about this metaphor yeah yeah
you heighten your reactivity to stimuli
by tucking in the the cannabis which
increases salience than that and then
you go to this novel environment which
is the melody and by being more
receptive to the melody the melody is
instrumenting you not to mention that
the cannabis is also hitting a sustain
pedal on that which is being
instrumented so you're basically taking
for a magic carpet ride in the now
followed by more now followed by more
now followed by more now and by the time
you pop out on the other side you have
this feeling that time disappeared from
that experience you know and then
there's a guy called Mark Leviton I
believe I wrote a book about the
neuroscience of music yeah Daniel
Levitin
Daniel Levitin so he had a section where
he was talking about why people enjoy
listening to music when they're high on
cannabis he says by the way in the
middle of here it's another book you
should read copy organize mind okay that
if you if people just listening if you
want certain if you just a little geeked
on neuroscience you just want to know a
general over how the brain works his
organized mind is amazing he has a
section in there on flow and talks about
how flow hits does specifically activate
some of broadens less with your language
centers okay does make sense a lot in
that and so what he was saying is that
the same short-term memory disruption
that is actually a feature a utility of
cannabis the same thing that Michael
Pollan was saying your pool of sense
impression fills button drains as
quickly as it fills with bathes
experience in this interesting texture
he says that that's what makes me listen
to music so much more potent when you're
in cannabis induced flow because you
stopped predicting what's coming next in
the song so you're experiencing the song
note to note precisely because the short
term memory disruption so when you're
hearing music and you're experiencing
the music note to note the part of you
that's heard the song before that's
predicting
what's gonna happen next and that goes
away so you're actually experiencing the
music note to note just cannabis right
all you need is flow like we'll do that
to write flow we'll do a t-shirt
no no cannabis required to say but it's
the same chemical and Sunanda my Amanda
mine which the brain naturally becomes
intensely so I guess that's that's a
beautiful phrase or a melody to
describing the the halo of being in the
flow of the present that is literally
full of wonder wonder being the
byproduct of an unencumbered sense of
first sight to which the adult brain has
closed itself that unencumbered sense of
first sight is essentially living life
note to note you're fully in the halo of
the present you're living it as it
happens and there's a freedom in that
because the inner chatter is a pushed
away obliterated why it feels so good
energy
I mean I'm commit feel so good to me
well this happens in flow this happens a
little bit kid I was the prefrontal
cortex right part of your brain that's
right back here gets really quiet and
flow right and your inner critic that
which is it lives in the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex mostly um which is out
here basically dorsal means up lateral
means side right like so um dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex is the OP
outside front part of my brain whatever
for you know people who hear these terms
and know what the it's a fancy way they
say up front here the braid is really
hard to navigate we've got lots of weird
language for where things are but uh
that's what all those fancy words mean
and also I do have to say I wish
neuroscientists would just settle on a
set of terminology because the brain is
in math like seven different times and
everything's got like fifteen different
names it's really anyways um that's
where your inner critic lives right and
that gets dialed down transient
temporary hypofrontality right the
temporary deactivation of the prefrontal
cortex shows up and flow also shows up
with cannabis right a little different
but very similar and that's so your
inner critic is going away yeah plus
plus everything else we've been talking
about right
Shaylee and all the stimulation not only
reaction gone but the voice in your head
that normally go when you have that
normal reaction that voice in your head
they go to see a loser yeah of course
that was going to happen that's right so
not only what the predictions gone but
your predictive reaction right your
psychosis that's like by the time you're
an adult is tied to your predictions
that's what Ernest Becker said he says
psychosis is just neurosis pushed to its
extreme that's very interesting man
answer I'm trying to like kind of
harness that into all these tangents but
we're essentially we're talking about
flow we're talking about building our
lives around flow we're talking about
the fact that flow requires just as much
discipline as it does surrender that
there's a kind of cult of surrender of
people that just expect flow to happen
all the time and it really can't and
that there's a lot of fetching water and
chopping wood and flow cycles and rest
cycles and all this discipline that goes
in to orient in your life around this
state then we've talked about the
different triggers that we can kind of
bring into the preconditions that we can
work with to get ourselves more flowing
this includes novelty and travel and
exposure to art violating expectations
taking up a new hobby and then of course
taking exogenous chemicals we're talking
a lot about about cannabis and flow so
perhaps we can give some closing
thoughts about the relationship between
flow and just other ecstatic altered
states of consciousness like how much do
other altered states build on flow how
are they parallel so how are they
happening side by side because we live
again in stealing fire your word about
the altered states economy the trillion
dollars a year that people spend to get
out of their heads is that just
basically them getting into flow or
trillion but before trillion because
they want to go to the movies they go to
concerts they want to get drunk on
alcohol they want to take vacations they
want to smoke joints they maybe go to
Burning Man and maybe take other
psychedelics so how much of the alter
States economy
builds on just flow or is it like like
is it flow Plus is it flow and so
because I don't want this to feel like
we're just like peddling substances that
people take to get
hi this is actually about something that
no brain naturally produces and it just
so happens that there's lubricants that
can help us get there like flow triggers
like cannabis like concerts like Beauty
like art like travel you know chicks at
man lie has argued very eloquent like
great article that you can't so he
there's a textbook they put out a
textbook of chicks at me eyes collected
works in the middle of the textbook is
this Italian he could did an interview
with this Italian magazine called flow
in the soul and they translated it and
the only copy you can find is in this
textbook but it's an astounding art of
how you always have good you have to
send me this Rick I'm gonna flow and the
soul written much except me hi so
Csikszentmihalyi it's so funny because
he the more and I've known him for a
while and the longer I am a student of
his work the more impressed I get every
time I find something else that he's
written he is really one of the better
philosophical thinkers of the 20th
century those guys this a psychologist
good right in well they usually are
right of course Ernest Becker Road now
deaf he was a psychoanalyst and he's I
think he's a philosopher he says that
everything we think of as art and a lot
of culture is are just literally the
byproducts of ways that we found to
produce flow so he Ernest Becker's
theory about denial of death he sort of
in its and they could both be right
right like so it's not our fear of death
it's just a response it's basically it's
our art is a trip report arkamada flow
art is a art is an attack it's a seeking
report it's like it's the byproduct
right but it's not the art is the it's
what happened the point was I want the
flow right and I and I want it because
it's hard here right like it's just hard
hits larger but go world that's right
and it hurts a lot that's round in flow
it goes away for a little bit right flow
redeems suffering it without a doubt
absolutely redeems as I always say this
about peak performance and so I have a
book that I'm working on right now
called the art one possible and it's a
big peak performance book it'll be out
in a couple years
and in it very Ron I point out to be a
woman look this is not a book about
happy or sad if you're happy or sad are
things that happen on the way to peak
performance right they're not like if
you're hung up on happy and sad and want
to get more happy and like don't do this
stuff performance is not pleasant right
you always just say this is the states
north of happy North the happiest are
those are you know all the authors say
so to get back to your tuba get back to
your question
so Csikszentmihalyi to flow in the soul
well all I was saying that was the art
and right I want to get to we there are
lot so the interesting flow is a very
controlled state right you're like
you're you garen total control it's
right your creative drive turned all the
way up but this is one of the six core
characteristics is a sense of control I
have control over my life
don't feel like you're not there at the
same you're not there but there's a
whole other category of altered state
experiences right which are the category
where you have no control
possession experiences for example there
are a lot of trance States right where
what you're doing is you're totally
giving up that control um some people
are why some people really like though
you know what I mean like I always I
always wonder some people you know I I
have friends who would take psychedelics
and they would go have conversations
with Norse gods and things like that and
I was like wow I just take psychedelics
and I'm just a I'm stone I'm just like
myself but I'm more [ __ ] up right it's
not like I don't know what you're doing
but I'm not like obvious the guy on
drugs they're having some kind of I
don't have that experience maybe it's
cuz I never let go of that control I
don't ever go I'd even with the MT I can
always find myself I always can find
myself in the experience and I have a
feeling that there are a whole bunch of
people who can't and the people who
can't they seem to love that experience
as much as I love flow right like so I'm
hesitant to judge an experience I don't
really have a deep understanding of at
all in terms of what's better what's
worse how did how do they relate I just
want to acknowledge that there's a you
know you
the altered state space control is a
really interesting nobody talks about it
really people often criticize me for
loving it so much because they say that
I'm missing out and I'm like yeah but
the moments when I actually feel the
most in control
I feel effortless effort so it's it's
it's control and surrender at the same
time I'm like the conductor of the
orchestra I'm doing a mazing job
conducting but I don't I don't feel like
I'm trying really hard to remain in
control the thing you're surfing but the
thing you always have to point out to
people is look like literally we're all
fundamentally wired different like right
like one of the reasons I'm just a guy
on drugs and psychedelic literature they
call me a hardhead right it means I need
massive quantities of certain substances
but it's not like it's not just
psychedelic substances and it's genetic
so when I go to have surgery I got to go
in and I got to be like guys you got to
give me two or three times as much
morphine because it won't work on me so
does my mother yeah it's genetic it's a
receptor sites are damp down blah blah
blah my point on this is people like
what they're wired for and they seem to
conflate what their own personal wiring
is was some kind of big metaphysical
cosmic thing so they can you know defend
it to you or their way is better like no
okay we're wired differently we like
this I like this so this is very
interesting because we have about eight
minutes left and maybe we can get a
little bit into this there's no doubt
that Orient's in your life around flow
identifying what your flow triggers are
creating a flow checklist being
disciplined about your surrender and
whatever it is that you output when
you're in flow whether it's painting or
dance or playing an instrument or
writing or an elite sport whatever or
coding or architecture business
everything that we know that it's you
know it's amazing cocktail of neural
chemistry that it can boost well-being
and health you know there's a million
thing there's a million reasons why we
should build our lives around flow I
mean it helped you recover from Lyme
disease surfing saved your life we never
got into the story but it's okay but I'd
like to talk about also what happens
particularly in the
on the edges of flow when you go into
like ego dissolving flow or
psychedelically mediated altered states
of consciousness experiences where
people you know go to these spaces in
the acronym is stir these places of
selflessness and timelessness and
richness and access to information
everyone yeah yeah when people spend too
much time in stir you know when they're
taking too many psychedelics and they're
just pushing that envelope you mentioned
this once
the problem with stir I mean the gift of
stir is that you're in the present and
how blissful and freeing that is but the
dangers of stir is that when you're in
the present when you're in that present
everything happens now so often people
can come out of these these edges of
flow these psychedelically addled flow
states when they're spending too much
time in there they have a rich interior
experience and that interior experience
I would argue is poetic truth not not
not empirical truth it's like that Allen
Dibble tone line where he says you know
a journalist a journalist may be more
accurate in describing the details of an
event than a poet but a poet may
nevertheless reveal truths of a deeper
sort that are beyond the literal grid
these are different domains of human
experience the outside of the inside
Ursula Le Guin says science describes
accurately from the outside
poetry describes accurately from the
inside science explicate SPO 'try
implicates right but these separations
are like church and state and so when
you have a spiritual flow
psychedelically mediated experience and
you have a poetic experience an
ineffable experience a communion with
the cosmos something that is
fundamentally poetry fundamentally
Church but then you come out of the
experience and you're preaching from the
perspective of fundamentally state like
you have an ego dissolving experience of
flow and then you'll be thinking now the
math people who go to these forms of
consciousness become like self-righteous
cult-like figures who think their [ __ ]
doesn't stink so where is the humility
post flow number one rule you never
trust the dopamine
never trust the dopamine and seriously
like don't go shopping in flow because
you've got massive amounts of dopamine
one things dopamine does is it amplifies
pattern right right um so you'll like it
for you buy everything don't believe
your apocalyptic visions in flow why one
your pattern recognition system is all
fired up so you're finding stuff links
right I'm the only one who sees them
want to ego dissolution this is one of
the giant puzzles psychology is what is
it about having your ego dissolve that
when it comes back it's twice bigger
than ever yeah it's bigger than a
mouthpiece of the universe and you know
why I always call my videos poetry
because I don't want anybody to ever
think that I'm having a Messiah Complex
or that there's any kind of
self-righteousness about the truth
behind what I'm saying as long as I call
my work a song or a poem I can take
poetic license to reflect upon my own
reflections out of a flow state linked
domains together and finds through lines
but I'm like hey man this freestyle rap
you know this is a poem when towing the
Church of Jason Silva I would make
myself sick but so many people want they
kind of want you to make that to cross
that threshold from like a scienter your
landscape and if you could resonate with
it
that's art beautiful but my interior
landscape has the mouthpiece of fact no
no no and too many people out there are
pretending to be the messengers because
were to God if I meet one more teenager
wear the funny hat it wants to put me
through a cacao ceremony I mean I swear
to God if I don't kill a millennial by
the end of my life I'll be lucky okay so
that said um no I like it's just it so
the other thing and two is is the danger
of timelessness is your point right is
when you're in a timeless space
everything feels really immediate so you
get a lot of people this is really I'm
seeing this a lot in the in the Burning
Man tech community right there's all
these apocalypse right now guys right
like running right and if the funniest
thing tomb is like dude were they not
around for like the year 2000 did they
not read like Daniel Pinchbeck is the
classic example and I
loved innocent nice guy breaking over
that it was a great book yeah but he
went down South America he did a lot of
drugs he didn't realize then the now
that he thought would write and he came
back and he wrote a book about how the
world is gonna end and blah blah and he
put a date on it and this is really
common right this is really common there
are known psychiatric syndromes based on
this kind of thing well yeah and this is
where I'd like to sort of wrap up is
like there we're we're celebrating and
rhapsodizing over how intoxicating and
healing and beautiful these domains of
consciousness are whether it's flow or
whether it's derivatives of flow and
altered states and the trillions of
dollars we spend every year to get out
of our heads and this beautiful but that
we must be careful with the revelations
or divinations that come through because
because what happens is so often what
comes through feels paranoid and
apocalyptic and there's always this idea
that like the system is about to
collapse and planetary collapse and
civilization will collapse and granted
there's things that are wrong in the
world there's things that need to be
addressed but my intuition is much more
Allah Steven Pinker Peter Diamandis
singularity University I see astounding
progress Stuart brand I see Kevin Kelley
at the long now foundation you don't see
them like freaking out about planetary
collapse as much as these the more
contemporary psychedelically addled
mouthpieces that we're seeing like I see
more progress is exactly about
cryptocurrency and psychedelics yeah
that seem to lead people to believe the
world is gonna add tomorrow like I don't
understand what what like well it's
pattern is City right well maybe that is
a sign it's a sign of psychosis seeing
patterns that aren't there but if you're
a sophisticated mind you can find
justifies one of the best ways to stop
this right not do this and one of the
best ways to hack flow right this is is
so with the at the end of a psychedelic
experience in a flow spirit you still
have the dopamine your brain your brain
is finding all those connections and the
actions and the actions cut it off
literally like go do some
thing walk away from the back end of a
flow state don't ride it to the bitter
end um but that's that's where a lot of
that stuff happens because the dopamine
is what's left and is looking for those
connections do you the ride even more
and try to um and I just think it's a
what are the odds that the universe
spoke specifically to you you you right
like what are the odds yeah right so you
just got it like ask yourself when you
have the big review you're like okay but
let's just like let's work the
statistics on this just for a second or
just remember that you know the big
reveal within the landscape or the
Kosmos of your mind might be the big
reveal that that that tells you you know
how you can heal your own life and move
forward the minute you try to be the
mouthpiece for everyone else you're
merging you're merging church and state
and let me show or treat your own poetry
your own ontological poetry to scripture
and we don't want that
your we don't want militancy we don't
want self-righteousness we don't want
anybody being the mouthpiece against
everyone else that's what we don't want
I also think and we got to wrap it up
soon by the way if you're I mean you're
well-read and philosophy you're
well-read and cycle so you know well
enough like when you have one of these
big ideas and you come back you can say
to yourself oh yeah well that was
Spinoza's idea before me or that you
know blah blah blah or I this is like as
I loved before I always want to find the
person who had an idea analogous to my
revelation and I want to cite them and
that says the work the rigor yes exactly
I meet so many people at Burning Man who
had one psychedelic experience they've
never read a book by William James
they've never read a book by Eric Davis
they've never read one of your books
they've never really paid attention to
any secular literature but they had one
second of the experience and now they're
like I really want to start a blog
because I have a message that I think
the world needs to listen to and I'm
like okay why should the world listen to
you have you done any actual fetching
water in chopping wood or you just had
one trip that told you you're the
Messiah and and you can tell they
haven't thought it through right you
just feel like all of a sudden they have
a message they want to share with the
world and feel entitled to share that
message
you should stop here use flow with
caution Stephen thank you for your time
I can talk to you for a thousand hours
so good cheers bro thank you all right